good morning John it is the 11th annual
project for awesome and that means that
I'm here to tell you about why solving
hard problems is so hard there's a bit
of a universal law in logistics that the
last little bit of transport that an
item has to do to get to its destination
is by far the most difficult leg of the
journey this is true in
telecommunications it's also true in
like your circulatory system it's called
the last mile problem weirdly enough it
takes almost as much energy and work to
get like something that I ordered off
Amazon say this from like China where
it's manufactured all the way to like
the distribution warehouse in Missoula
Montana as it does to get it from the
distribution warehouse in Missoula to my
house this is a very squeaky prop so
what's going on here the moment this
thing is manufactured in China it has
like one place to go to it goes to its
port and then from there from that port
it can go to like maybe a dozen or so
other ports in the world then when it
arrives at whatever port gets to it has
maybe a few thousand different
warehouses or stores that could end up
in if it ends up in a store it has to
wait for a person to go there and buy it
but if it's being shipped directly to
the person directly to me but it ends up
in this centralized local warehouse with
tens of thousands of other products and
those tens of thousands of products have
to go to potentially hundreds of
thousands of different individual places
99% of this thing's travels it could
have gone to like one of a few thousand
different places and that last 1% it's
gonna go to one of literally hundreds of
millions of places the last mile problem
is kind of why oftentimes when we have
really big ideas about how to fix things
those ideas don't work because when you
get to the last mile your one
overarching solution to all problems
becomes tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands of different solutions that
are all hard to work out and that's all
work like hard work and when it comes to
delivering health care or water or food
and parts of the world where those
things aren't available it used to be
work that just didn't get done but now
people are doing it organizations like
Save the Children and last mile health
and they solve the last mile problem for
health care the only way you can solve
it with problem-solver they work with
and train and in
loyd people from those communities to
become community health care workers
those people then help to grow the
economy to educate other people and to
keep their communities and thus the
entire global community more healthy so
this cost money but let me venture that
maybe this is one of the best things we
could possibly be spending money on as a
society but what if in addition to
helping fund that very cool work of
solving that very hard problem
you also get cool stuff well that's why
you should go to project for awesome
back home / donate where for the first
part of the project for awesome all of
the money up to seven hundred thousand
dollars will be mad and all that money
raised in the first half will be split
between last mile health and Save the
Children stuff you can get smash pennies
commemorative coin digital download
bundle with a bunch of different real
cool stuff and including outtakes seems
from Turtles all the way down at socks
and bandanas and I'm painting a bunch of
rocks lots of stuff some of it's already
sold out some of it as well on its way
to selling out including the project for
awesome charity calendar which I just
happened to have on the floor right here
includes this photo of B being splashed
in the face by champagne no it is not
photoshopped and yes I do know what it's
like to have champagne on the inside of
your sinuses during the second half of
the project for awesome all the money
raised will be split among charities
voted on by the community and the way
this works is people will make videos
promoting their favorite charities and
if you like those videos and you like
those charities you can vote on them at
project for awesome com the charities
think of the most votes will get a
portion of the money that we raised in
the second half the project for awesome
also the 48 hour charity livestream is
going on right now you could check it
out a project for awesome comm slash
live you can also probably just find it
on blog for the channel we'll be having
a lot of fun and doing a lot of weird
stuff and I really want you to join up
and if you want to make yourself happy
both with cool things that you can have
access to or you have shipped to your
house and with the knowledge that you
are helping solve some of the hardest
problems that humanity has left to solve
you can get a project for awesome calm
slash donate John I will see you in the
livestream